another black man has died after police
shot him in California yesterday
afternoon police responded to a 911 call
regarding an african-american man in his
thirties who reportedly was behaving
erratically behind a restaurant at the
broad Broadway village shopping center
according to the call the man was not
acting like himself and had been walking
in traffic in a manner that was
reportedly endangering both himself and
other motorists when officers contacted
him he failed to comply with the
directives that he was given according
to lieutenant Rob rands weiler Police
Chief Jeff Davis said that the man kept
his hands concealed in his pockets while
pacing back and forth and as a second
officer prepared a Taser the man quote
rapidly drew an opera an object placing
both hands on it quote like you would be
holding a firearm and stood in a quote
shooting stance according to police let
me show you the still image the picture
that some are saying confirms with the
police said is true if you see the man
standing by the white pickup truck here
you do see that his hands are up out
whether this is a still image that
captured his hands going up to a don't
shoot pose whether his hands were in
what is called a shooting stance at the
time different people with different
opinions here now in response one
officer fired his gun at the man while a
second officer almost simultaneously
discharged his taser eyewitnesses say
that the man did have his hands out when
he was shot not up and that he was
pleading not to be shot to police what
do we know about the victim named
unofficially as Alfred Elango reportedly
had mental health issues according to
Davis investigators did not find a
firearm at the scene of the shooting
investigators did not say what object
was found if any uh and whether or not
it was a weapon but nothing saying that
a weapon was found now one witness
reported seeing the man with the vape
electronic smoking device speculation is
that well maybe that's what the guy had
his hand uh police encouraging residents
to be patient
course video of this incident is not
going to be released until the local
district attorney has had a chance to
review it and early allegations that
local uh that individual cell phone
video had been uh confiscated by police
has been rejected by police police
saying no we did not confiscate
anybody's mobile phone so uh as far as
the health issue I mentioned individuals
saying this is a man with with mental
health issues other reports saying he
was epileptic well police are saying no
indication at all that at least the man
was at the time suffering from an
epileptic seizure many concerns about
protests and violence after what took
place in Charlotte after the police
shooting of kief Lamont Scott police
concerned as well here in California
that these uh protests many of which
started very very soon after gatherings
out of protesters even the right word
could continue to flare up uh what can
be done here right I mean what can be
done remember our investigation about
racial bias and police shootings we
determined that big picture it is not
true that quote black men are more
likely to be shot by police than white
men but it is true that once police
interactions have started unarmed black
suspects are more likely to be shot then
unarmed white suspect so very many
issues here Rachel intersectional issues
a number of different issues very very
difficult often to unpack it and say
what we should be focusing on X Y or Z
up but yet another one of these stories
and that's really the big picture the
stories keep coming one issue that I
kind of have is I don't really
understand why they say he wasn't acting
like himself that kind of scent sounds
more like a judgment to me and I kind of
understand describing someone's behavior
as erratic but to say that he wasn't
acting like himself are they a family
member were they dating him so that
specific statement I have a tiny bit of
an issue with also when we talk about
the shooting stance and what we have is
a still image I completely agree this
still image that we showed looks like a
quote shooting stance but what we have
here is a moment in time and without
actually seeing video of what was going
on this could have been someone who is
making a motion of get away from me
don't shoot this could have been someone
who was in the process of going from
this position to another position and I
think that we're not going to get to too
much by speculating just based on this
one image will continue to follow the
story